sitting here I'm still young and we want
to give a shout-out to Emmylou Harris
who helped you out beautiful gorgeous
song thank this old guitar and actually
just the other day I asked you about
that guitar because you're here with us
all week and I mentioned that it's a
very special guitar yeah it used to
belong to Hank Williams that just blows
me away
yeah me too it's a Martin it's a Martin
from is it from the 44 tees yeah
gorgeous
we're just guitar it's just magical you
know the folks here might not know us
but Conan's dressing room is Philip it's
full of guitars yeah we're gonna ask you
about this I have I I have guitars I
like to play I like to play a lot before
the show this is a true story I go in
just before the show to play one of my
guitars calms me down before I go out
and give away cash prizes to the
audience and I go in to check out one of
my guitars and and it's it's completely
out of tune I pick up another one
completely out of tune completely out of
tune and I said what's going on here
they're like yeah Neil Young came in and
put all your guitars out of tune you
tune them which way is that due to all
indie modal surprise cinema girls really
easy
well now that you've tuned them I can't
put them back so I got to keep them that
way yeah songs like that alright well
it's very nice you have to show me some
of the songs and you stick around
afterwards yeah okay I will
you're lying you know that was for TV
you pump this isn't real I mean oh yeah
yeah let me ask you something this is
fascinating to me you're you don't
usually do television you don't like to
do television and then you sign up for a
whole week with us what is it you don't
usually like about television doing a
television performance well I'm a
control freak so I can't I can't control
the audience I can't make myself real
loud mm-hmm and everything else like not
there that's what I like to do when I
play a concert and yeah it's kind of a
thing I like to be real loud right so
you're gonna actually be performing
again after this next commercial break
is there any you want to give
instructions to the people watching at
home right now exactly what they should
do yeah okay you tell them exactly what
you want and they will do it so you know
turning it way up you know as loud as
makes it all the way okay and and then
turn all the lights out okay and put on
some sunglasses and get ready
now I I want to get serious here for a
minute this is a spectacular album
Prairie wind and you wrote this album
after you learned that you had a brain
aneurysm and that you're gonna have to
be getting this life-threatening surgery
I prefer to think of a dead I had
something on my mind okay on my mind and
I had to have it taken off right okay we
do you find that that helped your
creative process staring something like
this in the face well if I you know
actually in the back of my mind it was
there while I was recording the record
and I think it you know it made me
reflect on things and everything because
you know you never know what's gonna
happen these guys are experts and you
know they're their greatest doctors in
the world and I felt very confident but
still in the back of your mind you
wonder what's what's gonna happen sure
so it's you almost feel like you
probably got this extra incentive to
just draw on all your creativity well I
just felt like if I had anything to say
I should say it you know and get it just
get it out there so people could know
you know like if I guess the worst thing
would be that I'd still be there but I
wouldn't be able to play or something
you know and and or wouldn't you know
whatever maybe not maybe that might not
be the worst thing but you know so it
was on my mind I just had to get it off
you know I had to get it out there all
right and you I want to mention this to
Jonathan Demi is as directed and he's in
the process of completing a film which
is a concert film is that right yeah
it's it's called heart of gold and it's
a concert film that Jonathan conceived
and filmed in in Nashville where women
at the Ryman Auditorium loppers original
home
when is that gonna be when are we gonna
be seeing that when will that be
available that comes out in the middle
of February all right so you'll come
back and do a month then yeah I'll be
back for a month well then I really
pushed that one yeah yeah okay yeah well
Prairie wind Prairie wind is is in
stores now I know you're you're playing
again but when we come back and then
you're gonna be here tomorrow night
but in case I don't get the chance to
say it tomorrow this has been an
incredible thrill for everyone here and
thank you so much for being here for me
to Conan I got to say it I mean this
place there's a lot of fun to be and
everybody here a backstage and in the
hallways they're all having a good time
and everybody's happy to be here and
I've been a lot of different places
where it's not that way so I think it's
great whatever you're doing you just
keep on doing it
[Applause]
these guys are all loaded right now
everybody you're gonna you're gonna want
to be here when we come back Neil Young
take a break right